people don't realize that you can be you
the two things can be true at once you
can be pro-trans rights
but also pro-women's rights and
unfortunately
there's a line that's being crossed into
women's rights territory and that's when
i started
really seeing the divide with me and the
left
hey i'm dave rubin and joining me today
is a former lefty
turn conservative a youtube creator
and a card carrying lesbian here to talk
about what's going on with the gay
community
arielle scarcella welcome to the reuben
report
thank it's been long overdue yeah you
said this vlog
but like girl everyone everyone says
that i'm the female dave rubin and at
first
i was like do they mean that in a bad
way and some of them do
but like i know it's a good thing even
though they might think bad things so
either way
i'm flattered no matter how they mean it
i'm flattered either way
much obliged and i'm glad you're here
and we are
putting this interview out during pride
month the gays get a whole month
i introduce a card-carrying lesbian is
it true that lesbians have a card do you
have some sort of laminated card
i mean i i mean i think it's more that
we
now we have to have a card because now
we can't even define the damn word
yeah right like nobody even knows how to
find a woman we can't define
lesbian so i feel like we need to have a
card that says like
this is what a lesbian means to me this
is the card
this is what i am and this is what i
want right kind of like gay hanky code
back in like the 70s you know when they
had the hanky code
the older game get that reference the
older gays get that i i get the
reference but it's a little bit
before my time but i wanted to have you
on for a while because you
are when people say that you're the
you're the girl dave rubin or something
to that effect
you left the left and you survived so
could we just do like a two minute recap
because it's pretty recent for you it's
only in the last couple years you were
elected
and you woke up that's exactly what
happened
i think looking back now the past
four years you know of my content making
because i'm an og youtuber i've been
making videos since 2009 like before
youtube was even a career option
yeah that's before me like years before
me
exactly like we were just online having
fun being kids
i was like 23 at the time 24 and
now you know looking back
my entire outlook on the community has
has changed
back then it was it was everybody was
humble everyone got along there was like
some
drama here and there but usually it had
to do with who was dating who and who
broke up with who
not with how someone identified or who
wants to sleep with who
um and the last five years i noticed
a huge change in the youtube community
especially the gay community the lgbt
community on youtube
it became volatile volatile whatever the
i don't know how to pronounce the word
because i'm from
i'll accept either one you're a brooklyn
girl
right but you know it became it just
toxic honestly
um and it started i would say it started
with
the trans community and then it filtered
into
the bisexual non-binary queer whatever
anything other than lesbian community
and then now it's starting to filter
down into the gays and lesbians and it
started to hit me
when i started making content about
trans people with trans people by the
way
trans people were in the videos but i
got sick
of feeling like everyone was attacking
me
for simply having a different opinion
and it wasn't
it to me in my opinion it wasn't even
like a non-mainstream of opinion that's
the weird part right like this is a
pretty like it's based on logic and
science yeah what
what was your highly controversial
opinion on the trans issue
oh my god there's so many highly highly
controversial
transphobic opinions that i have but one
of them is i don't think somebody is a
lesbian
you know if they want to want to suck a
dick so
can i say that on your show you can i
think it's the first time it's been said
but
it's definitely the first time but like
that's not controversial
it shouldn't be controversial and
somehow yet it is
um i i think socially it makes a lot of
sense when there are trans women who
present
as women like you know my friend
blairway like my friend ashley
socially they'll always be women because
they don't long they no longer live
their lives as men
and i i have you know i've had that
opinion for years and i started speaking
out
you know about that kind of stuff
because people don't realize that
you can be you the two things can be
true at once you can be pro-trans rights
but also pro-women's rights and
unfortunately
there's a line that's being crossed into
women's rights territory and that's when
i started
really seeing the divide um with me and
the left
and i i was going to stand by my morals
no matter what because i'm a new york
italian
and i finally made a video actually
connected with tim poole who's been a
friend of mine way before he
got big on youtube um i connected with
him and i went over his house
and i was like i'm i need help like i
don't know what the hell to do
but i'm being attacked constantly i've
lost
50 or plus creator friends of mine and
i also contacted my friend sydney watson
who i think you know and
she and tim helped me write the video
and i i posted the video and i just
prayed to god honestly i i didn't know
what to expect i really didn't i was
just
tired of being mentally and emotionally
abused
and i even made a video about that about
how all the tactics that the progressive
left
uses these days are emotionally like
psychological emotional abuse tactics
you know like the whole thing like
trying to get you fired making sure that
you only talk to certain people
like crazy [ __ ] that i've been in
abusive relationships before
i started seeing the red flags i wasn't
completely convinced at first because i
was like okay just like they're just a
bunch of kids
but then my friends my ex-friends
started doing it to me and i was like
okay like this is
i have to put an end to this and not
allow myself to be
um taken advantage of anymore
so i think the million-dollar question
that that all gay people get asked when
they
come out as anything other than
progressive is
which was harder to come out of the
closet or
to come out as a conservative or someone
that is just non-progressive
it was harder coming out of the closet
to
myself it was harder coming out of the
closet
as a gay person it was harder coming out
of the closet as a non-progressive to
the world i mean because it wasn't about
yeah because it was about how they saw
me not how i saw myself like i always i
always knew
that i was sort of like at this point in
my life i think i'm pretty much like
fiscally conservative social libertarian
socially libertarian like live and let
live don't touch me
like let me do what i want with my
bodies pretty much you know don't take
my money
give me my guns like i understand guns
right now right wing extremist stuff
yeah of course like white nationalists
everything you know but
like that's where i'm at now and i think
part of it also is
moving down to florida part time made a
big difference in the way i thought
because
you know new york city is super
progressive florida is a little bit more
of a red state
and i got that perspective and helped me
i guess
centralize maybe my opinions on certain
issues um
and i made you know the best part of
this all
is i made better friends from it like
better friends that
like now when i get like online bullied
or harassed whatever
the people that on the left never would
help never ever
would stick up for me all the people on
the right
all these terrible people that
everyone's making it out to make it out
to seem
like they're terrible people all of them
always come to my defense every single
time
i stay
yeah and and it's it's just it's
mind-blowing to me how
opposite it
is compared to what the media portrays
them to be if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification
bell